[Música]
salud en directo América de Francia 24
sala como siempre Todas las mañanas en
nuestro estudio mar bienvenida bueno
saludarla hoy Vamos hasta los
laboratorios de alta seguridad lugares
donde se manejan virus altamente
contagiosos Marc que está pasando en el
mundo con esas instalaciones Buenos días
Raúl digamos que está viendo un Boom no
el Kobe 19 despertó la necesidad de
tener más de estos laboratorios que
puedan manejar este tipo de virus
estamos hablando nivel 3 nivel 4 que son
de los más altos en los niveles de
bioseguridad por ejemplo en todo el
mundo hoy en día hay planes de
construcción para 27 laboratorios nivel
4 en todo el mundo países como China
India Singapur filipinas están
desarrollando este tipo de Laboratorios
Y estos planes no todo esto tiene varias
implicaciones algunas positivas algunas
negativas las vamos a hablar todas con
Óscar Franco epidemiólogo y director del
departamento de salud pública de la
Universidad de utrecht muy buenos días
doctor y muchas gracias por acompañarnos
un miércoles más aquí en salud de Franz
24 que son estos laboratorios empecemos
por el principio no porque nos debería
interesar Qué está pasando con ellos
Sí en total lo que estamos viendo Es de
los de los niveles más altos de
bioseguridad a niveles 13 y 4 se van a
construir y se están construyendo 40
laboratorios en todo el mundo y los
países que más están construyendo son
Rusia e India si le pasamos la
bioseguridad el nivel 1 es el más bajo
se manejan agentes que no poseen
realmente un alto riesgo para para los
seres humanos en el nivel 2 ya ya hay
agentes mucho con más alto nivel de
riesgo de riesgo moderado Por así
decirlo Como por ejemplo el VIH o la
influenza en el nivel 3 ya ya se manejan
agentes que pueden tener transmisión por
aerosoles Pues en más alto riesgo por
ejemplo la tuberculosis y en el nivel 4
ya son los los agentes ya mucho más
peligrosos como el ébola que pueden
causar la muerte y que se pueden
transmitir también por vía aérea nos
debería interesar Sí sí porque poseen un
riesgo para la población pueden ocurrir
accidentes segundo pueden tener
beneficios necesitamos hacer
investigación y tercero Porque pueden
costar muchísimo no solo construir sino
también mantenerlos entonces si no
debería interesar
doctor los saludo nuevamente un gusto
que esté de nuevo con nosotros o qué
país este tiene la mayoría de estos
laboratorios que ya existen y digamos
que quiero preguntar si están
distribuidos de forma desigual
muy desigual de hecho tenemos 63
laboratorios de máxima seguridad en todo
el mundo desde el nivel cuatro dos están
por ejemplo los Estados Unidos y la
mayoría están en otros países en Europa
también están en Rusia y en China y
África y Suramérica por ejemplo no tiene
ninguno entonces vemos que ahí hay una
desigualdad en el acceso a ese tipo de
Laboratorios que ayudan muchísimo para
la investigación y que podrían ayudar
también para responder epidemias y
emergencias como la que estamos viviendo
precisamente no estaba hablando del
Ébola de la tuberculosis Cuál es Cuáles
son las ventajas de que los laboratorios
estén más cerca de los países que
realmente están afectados por estas
enfermedades no Qué diferencias
podríamos ver si estos laboratorios se
construyeran en los lugares que estaban
mencionando
los beneficios es que estos laboratorios
podrían ayudar a los investigadores a
los científicos a desarrollar mejores
medidas para para poder manejar este
tipo de emergencias como la pandemia que
estamos viviendo otras epidemias pero
también para poder entender mejor el
comportamiento estos agentes para poder
entender como manejar su resistencia
ante los tratamientos poder desarrollar
mejores vacunas o vacunas nuevas y todo
este tipo de investigación se
facilitaría por eso es tan importante y
por eso Muchos investigadores están
reclamando de que se construyan estos
laboratorios en sus lugares de trabajo
doctor no todo el mundo sin embargo
aplaude esta expansión de los
laboratorios del que estamos hablando
qué contras tiene esto
en primer lugar porque puede haber
accidentes en el que se pueden
desarrollar nuevos virus o nuevos
agentes estos pueden escapar por un
accidente de hecho si recordamos todos
de dentro de los hipótesis sobre el
origen del Kobe del coronavirus que nos
está afectando estaba un accidente en un
laboratorio esto no sea todavía
confirmado ni descartado todavía se está
investigando por otro lado Los costos
son enormes no solamente construirlos
sino el mantenimiento de un laboratorio
de estos puede ser de 12 millones en el
costo al año solo el mantenimiento Y
también porque se puede usar para para
cosas que no sean no son tan buenas Como
por ejemplo el bioterrorismo o Se
podrían usar para guerra biológica como
arma biológicas entonces por eso es que
muchas personas ven esto con algo de de
perspicacia con mucha precaución
sí doctor sin embargo yo quería
preguntarle No qué tan factible Es
realmente que haya patógenos que escapen
de sus laboratorios y eso sí de algo que
en algunas ocasiones hemos visto pero
también esta creación de patógenos
nuevos que puedan ser utilizados para
bioterrorismo por ejemplo no es es un
riesgo real o es algo que que la ficción
también a veces pues nos ha intuido en
la cabeza
es una realidad es una realidad absoluta
que puede ocurrir de hecho en una
investigación que se publicó en el 2020
se preguntó al personal de estos
laboratorios se había tenido accidentes
que no reportaron y hasta el 25 al 30%
del personal reportar que tuvieron
accidentes y que no lo reportaron es
posible que estén ocurriendo más
accidentes de los que nosotros sabemos
también el 40% solo el 40% del personal
reportó que utilizaban todas las medidas
de seguridad que son necesarias en este
tipo de laboratorio para evitar
accidentes accidentes también se han
reportado a través de la historia y ver
que lo más famosos y 1967 está el
accidente en el laboratorio mármol que
es una ciudad al norte de Frankfurt en
Alemania donde varios trabajadores
desarrollaron diarrea vómitos y fiebre
no se sabía que era lo que tenían se
fueron una investigación se encontró que
era un virus que venía en dos simios
importados de uganda para investigación
sobrepolio y este virus nunca se había
detectado antes de estos trabajadores
siete fallecieron al virus se le llamó
el virus de marlbour por la ciudad y
desde entonces hemos tenido varias
epidemias Como por ejemplo en angora en
el 2005 donde fallecieron 200 personas
entonces no es ficción lo hemos visto en
películas y creemos que está ahí
solamente Pero la realidad es que los
accidentes sí ocurren y ocurren más de
lo que nosotros creemos
doctor como siempre Muchísimas gracias
por la información más Muchas gracias a
ti también Raúl y por supuesto doctor
Franco y nosotros de esta manera
concluimos nuestro segmento de salud por
el día de hoy para saludar a nuestra
segunda invitada del día